how many years have you been writing
screenplays I have been writing
screenplays that include television
scripts because I think my very first
one I tried to write a Cosby Show
episode when I was in college so that
was probably 25 years something like
that 20 to 25 years ago I think in that
was my first script someone gave me like
a spec Cosby script and I was like oh I
think I can I can do this I love that
show I think I can do this so I
literally just sort of used it as the
format back then there was no final
draft none of that stuff you just had to
figure it out right so um back then and
I'm making myself seem so old so um I
just like did the format and I did a
Cosby script and I think it was about um
oh gosh it was like a Spelling Bee
script like Rudy wanted to win the
spelling bee or something like that so
about between 20 and 25 years something
like that thank you and had you always
wanted to write because it sounds like
you were journaling before that but so
you went to school in the DC area I went
to American University and I also took
classes at Howard okay yeah and was that
part of the plan like you knew that then
you were coming to LA or no I never
expected to end up in LA I was I
actually started out as a journalist and
I was doing journalism I was a youth
correspondent in Richmond Virginia which
is where I'm from and I wrote some news
stories I went to a couple of journalism
workshops over the summer one in Arizona
and all this other stuff so I was really
on that path but then when I got to
school I realized that in order to be a
journalist because I still I loved
writing I was writing when I was younger
I would write really bad rhyming couplet
poems romantic unrequited love because I
used to read a lot of Harlequin romance
novels and silhouette novels when I was
a kid I would read these they wouldn't
so all of my bad poetry was like rhyming
couplets and so I did that for a long
time
so I've always been riding and they told
me that in order because I wanted to
write features like feature articles the
fun stuff the creative stuff and they
were like oh no you don't really get to
do that until you've sort of paid your
dues by like writing about politics and
all that kind of stuff and I was like I
am so not interested in that it would be
different today today politics is
exciting and it's opinionated and we're
all into it but back then it was boring
they were like you have to go to
Congress and take notes about that and I
was just like yeah I'm good I'm gonna
take a creative writing class and kind
of go down that path okay so I started
acting that's out so that's that was the
crossover acting and then scripts
playwriting thin script writing it sort
of went and not in that way in that
order yeah in that order thank you in
that order that's the way I wanted to
say that so what does writing mean to
you because obviously it's been in you a
long time whether it's the poems or
wanting to be a journalist but it sounds
like there's something that do you feel
almost you express yourself in a totally
different way once you're putting the
pen to the page or keyboard yes and I
would say that's a great way to ask that
question if I express myself in a
totally different way because even when
I write emails some of my my girlfriends
and some of my boyfriend's if in the
past would be like oh yeah she writes
extremely tense email writer what do you
want for me I feel like I expressed
myself just more clearly and there's no
reading between the lines when I write
it in an email it's exactly what it is
that I want to say right I feel like I
can see everything and there's nothing
left out when I write an email so I feel
that way sometimes when I'm writing
definitely in my journal and for other
things like more creative endeavors like
screenwriting
it's just the characters speak through
me and that's like what's amazing and
fun because I never know what they're
going to
what they're gonna do sometimes I'll
pull stuff from people that I know and
put them in the characters mouth that
kind of thing you know you're never
saving around a writer they're always
taking notes so you know you just say
hey everything's fair game anything you
say may end up in a script I want to
sign it to you but I ended up in a
script so I just think in that way it's
just fun to have the characters really
like come through you and live through
you and I think somatically is is what's
connected to you like there's always
something that is connected to you in
some spiritual or experiential way but
it's a surprise when these characters do
stuff that maybe you didn't expect them
to do or they say something you didn't
expect them to say and that that's
really fun is writing another way of
allowing yourself to be honest because I
know for women we have to be very
careful in our tone and sommes we're
groomed to like end things in a question
sometimes I know people would debate me
on that but we have to be careful that
we don't do you think with writing it's
easy to just be honest and say it and
there's no like we don't assign judgment
to it oh yes I would say when you're
really being authentic as a writer then
definitely it's a way of being honest
and true and I think people really
respond to authenticity and they know
when you're not being authentic when I
wrote my first screenplay my brother
who's an incredible writer like he he
started writing screenplays and now he's
a novelist and I actually tried to get
him to write my very first screenplay
jar by the door I had written a
treatment for it
and he was like oh this is great this
could be a really good script no I'm not
gonna write it for you learn how to
write write it yourself I was like but
you do it already you were like nope you
have to do it so the reason I brought
him up was he was the first person to
read my very first draft and he read it
and he was like this is really great
it's almost there but there's stuff in
it that is not real it's not authentic
and you're just kind of not you're sort
of touching at some stuff but you're
dancing around it and he's like you
really have to take the gloves off and
be
you reel with your characters and let
them talk in a real way and he was
specifically talking about the lead
character which was slightly fashioned
after me and he was like that's not a
real person yeah it was like maybe it's
too close to you but you have to let go
of that and just let it be authentic how
that person would respond even yourself
you've made her too nice and too good
and too and I was like but that is
meaning is like right we get a little
truth in here so I rewrote it with his
notes and it's like a much better script
because I let the characters really be
human and real and messy and all that
stuff you know
is it hard to let a protagonist have
faults because we we don't want to judge
them but it's just part of being human I
think when I first started writing
scripts it was what once I learned that
lesson from my brother I really
understood that the characters are more
interesting and they're more people can
relate to them more so they're more
relatable when they do have faults
because we all do and when we actually
show those faults it's sort of it
balances everything out you know because
there's something that people can relate
to and you know any character that has
faults I mean it's more I think we do it
more of these days than we did before
yeah so like you might have a Vil a
villain who has some really nice
qualities or you have the protagonist
who has some really just awful qualities
we still root for him and we still like
it we're like well you know everybody
has their stuff even this person and
that's a good point I think in the 80s
we had more of a like the thing you're
pretty in pink or something like yeah
the character there wasn't anything
really that she did that was awful no we
wanted her to win but she didn't really
have a dark side yeah really yeah we did
a guy yes and ducky
I mean hey no
you